governor andrew cuomo facing scrutiny as
he should after
finally reversing course for covid 19
patients in nursing homes
this comes as florida governor ron
desantis touts his early action to
protect
the elderly deen you're focusing those
efforts
where the threat really exists which is
in our senior population
so we did very early uh with the nursing
homes we restricted visitation and we
prevented
hospitals from discharging covid
positive patients
back into nursing homes that's like a
tinderbox if you let that happen
sounds like common sense to me not new
york our next guest says the drastically
different approaches
offer life and death consequences check
out his new piece at fox news opinion
here to explain fox news contributor roy
murdock roy good morning thanks for
being here
i mean the media the media has held up
cuomo as the example of leadership in
this moment but when you actually look
at the two states and the elderly
population
it's a massive contrast it's a huge huge
difference and a very sad difference
yeah
here in new york state mario cuomo had
the brilliant idea on march 25
to tell nursing home patients you must
take uh people who are covet 19 positive
people who might have gone to the
hospital and been discharged once they
became more medically stable
uh they were not allowed to send them
away in fact they were not even required
to that they be tested
uh as a result a lot of these folks went
back to nursing homes people got sick
nursing homes which had not been touched
by covert 19 suddenly became
hotbeds of covet 19 and unfortunately a
lot of seniors in nursing homes started
dying in huge numbers
uh the death toll right now is about
5300 something like that
and android as we know there's a there's
a very large senior population in
florida if anyone would have had the
possibility for a breakout like that
they took the exact opposite approach
saying we know who is most afflicted and
affected by this let's protect them
exactly right and they send teams in to
inspect these
nursing homes they sent people and make
sure the nursing homes had all the
equipment
they needed they gave them additional
training on how to avoid infections
and the result so far has been about 665
uh folks seniors dead in nursing homes
in florida the death rate in florida is
about three per hundred thousand
in new york state is 27.5 per hundred
thousand so about nine
times worse absolutely absolutely well
we see them
will we see the media ever really uh
expose this contrast that cuomo finally
reversed course after defending
putting kovid into nursing homes will
they ever hold him to account for that
uh you know they really should and it'd
be one thing if all the other hospitals
were full
but we had the javits center about
one-third empty we had the usns comfort
the
hospital ship the president trump trump
sent up here uh that had 182 beds filled
out of a thousand
so it's not like there were alternatives
to send people where they could go and
be isolated not get
healthy seniors infected and ultimately
killed uh
maricoma really i'm sorry andrew cuomo
really needs to be held to account
on this and i wish the media would do it
hearing a little bit of criticism here
in new york but i don't hear very much
nationwide
no that's true well you're doing
yeoman's work at foxnews.com droid thank
you for joining us this morning we
appreciate it thank you pete good to see
you brother